wow that's very uh local tv
welcome to is this effective the segment
where we test mysterious ointments that
are sent to us from viewers
[Laughter]
but it's also
a chance for me to force you to watch
weird stuff i found on the internet with
me sorry governor okay first up an ad
from poland it's one with a twist that
may involve a tryst show it
[Music]
well i know what you're thinking that's
one sexy showroom over at raymore and
flanigan's
i don't know what they were saying but
wait
there's more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this ad is meant to shame people
who park in handicapped spaces
when they're not disabled it's called
don't occupy the spot of those who need
it and i guess the lesson is how would
you like it if i parked in your wife
which seems
which seems kind of crude
but i guess the guy i should thank god
uh
he didn't park in the fire lane
then this lady really would have been
hosed
a tasteless sexist would say who writes
this garbage emily it's disgusting i am
appalled was the ad effective well
here's the thing so the version that i
watched didn't have the english
translation so it was up to me to like
extrapolate what was happening so in my
head she was sleeping with him because
he had the disabled parking placard
which is obviously priceless
that's a better angle i don't fault her
that's a better angle i am a cat i was
watching this i found the guy in the
wheelchair to be very smarmy
very so i think that forget that he was
in a wheelchair i found his personality
to be
a problem yeah look at him cocky
cocky
holder yeah he doesn't call him yeah
well no he's he's not the cook the other
guy is he's like you're doing that now
the cocker
yeah exactly those are actual terms i'm
well aware did you like this commercial
well i think it would be more effective
if they just instead just made it a law
yeah yeah
if you take somebody's parking spot then
they get to bang your wife
[Laughter]
you should run for office
[Applause]
i'm not going to bring that bill no
you're not going to break i'm not going
to bring that bill
[Music]
oh man stay out of this country hoping
to get a spot on your staff yeah
do you think this analogy was
appropriate or is it kind of crass
the idea of comparing a part of your
spouse to a parking space
jamie
he's divorced by the way so
you've just basically you brought you
know what i think you just micro
triggered him
i will say i think the guy who's doing
the cheating the disabled guy and the
guy coming home could at least use the
same excuse for what they did they could
be like oh i'm just delivering a package
i'll just be a minute
well i was just is that a couch is that
a kid yeah why the couch i was trying to
figure that out yeah why the couch did
is it were they they must have had this
discussion that it had to be on a couch
and not in a bed where was this
i was in poland they do have advertising
you're polish sure am yeah
you proud of this work yeah i'm proud to
be polish all right good for you
well i think we'll end on that note
thanks everyone
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else